hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back with more
hunting glory
however we are here to examine some
parts of the series that may be a little
less glorious and that's because
yoshihiro tagashi is an undeniably
brilliant but sometimes problematic
author due to his very improvised style
because for example the anatomy of your
standard hunter hunter arc goes a little
something
like this togashi has fun idea for a
setting togashi begins writing story
around that fun setting tagashi gets
distracted by something shiny and then
togashi immediately ends arc to begin a
new one based on the shiny thing that he
just saw
and weirdly enough i don't mean that as
a criticism in fact it's one of the
things i love most about hunter hunter
the fact that at any time events can
cease and brand new unpredictable parts
can emerge it's very interesting because
it actively spits in the face of purely
planned stories and it does so almost
unbelievably successfully however when
you do look at hunter hunter as an
overall body of work togashi's weekly
spot at the manga improv club
does leave us with a couple of glaring
inconsistencies
problems that more than likely would not
have arisen in a planned story and while
none of these
or at least most of these are not series
breaking they do come kind of close
because there are some pretty bad ones
in here and our exploration is going to
begin with a quick round of accidental
assassin a very simple minigame the
rules of which are as follows
you have walked into a room containing
three zoldic family members and it is
going to be your job to guess which one
of them has been contracted to
assassinate you before they carry out
the act
should you guess incorrectly then well
sorry but as further after life
punishment you will need to subscribe to
the new world review thus resulting
consistent injections of hunt and
culture administered directly into your
youtube feed
meanwhile if you are correct then you
will receive a 10 discount on all future
zoldic services so which zoldic will it
be make your choice now and we shall
reveal the answer in
three two one and bam it was zeno never
underestimate the elderly so if you
guessed incorrectly then you know the
thing to do and please do say hi in the
comments below if you are a recent
inductee of our association
welcome xeno leads quite nicely into one
of the most gigantic glaring
inconsistencies of hunter hunter thus
actually qualifying as a full-on plot
hole and rather sadly this occurs during
one of my favorite moments of the series
which is the commencement of the palace
invasion where zeno invokes the dragon
dive technique meanwhile at the same
time the extermination team emerged to
encounter yupi however we dwell on kilwa
for a bit because
and i quote kilauea the only one who
knew it was happening
froze because of it the shock for the
others being ignorant was much greater
and then killer even states that this is
his grandfather's dragon dive ability so
in the heat of the moment yeah this
makes perfect sense i mean of course
kilauea would know his family's
techniques however the big problem here
is that kilauea had
no concept of men prior to the heaven's
arena arc not even the basics so it's
hard to come up with a point in time
where he would have actually seen this
ability in action so it is quite
bizarre that he is able to recognize
something so distinct
and look it's not without potential
explanation this is one of the bigger
debated plot holes within the hunt onto
fandom and i suppose it is possible that
a very
very young killer saw this ability being
performed at some stage without actually
being able to see it you know the the
aura dragon heads and stuff or that
killer had been told that this was what
his grandfather was capable of doing and
he just put two and two together during
this whole invasion thing but it's such
a long-winded explanation when
the simple and most likely correct
answer is that well
tagashi forgot and funnily enough having
killua noticed dragon dive was probably
a preemptive move
to plug a potential plot hole of well
how come killua didn't know that his
grandfather was there hmm
so togashi being clever turned into
exactly what i suspect he was trying to
prevent and like i said in the intro
something like this is not series
breaking and if you do
scrub your mind hard enough then you can
clean your way down to like a maybe
explanation but it's just one of those
things that makes you go
huh that well that shouldn't have
happened as does a lot to do with the
phantom troop because their betrayal is
uh well it's inconsistent
i often reference how odd it is that
crollo and the crawl bros can walk
around so freely when they are pretty
much
public enemy number one all over the
world because sometimes the troop will
be treated like the secret shadow
organization that everyone knows about
but nobody has ever seen
whilst at other times the trooper
treated like a band of celebrities who
get recognized in an instant by
absolute nobodies and for the sake of
argument let's say that the phantom
troop were all completely unknown prior
to york new city there are arguments
that might say otherwise but it doesn't
matter because
during and after york new city the large
majority of the troops were revealed in
one way or another whether it be via the
fake corpses left by corto abu's ability
or the actual photos that were spread of
the troop but despite that the story
continues to treat the troop depending
entirely on the needs of the story
itself
for example crollo not only went on to
become a floor master of heaven's arena
but he
actively fought hisoka in a very very
public televised match
and this was well after crollow's name
and face had been discovered so it does
boggle the mind ever so slightly that he
can participate in such a public
spectacle without any kind of
authorities becoming involved in
attempting to do something like say i
don't know
capture the world's most wanted criminal
something like that but then you also
have situations like on the black whale
one where nobunaga finx and phaeton were
recognized on-site by the weenie who is
for all intents and purposes a
kakin scrub nobody but then you can also
do stuff like take a step back to greed
island where bisky doesn't even
recognize the name
much less the face of crawler so it's
hard to pin down on one hand togashi
plays them as this niche industry legend
but on the other they're also a group of
world-renowned terrorists it's the same
sort of dynamic that you have with the
zoldic family being world famous
assassins but also needing to maintain a
stealthy nature for their jobs and thus
nobody ever recognizes them in public
unless they do and that's kind of the
general thing about all established
rules and law of hunter hunter we follow
them
until we don't and then we start
following them again when we need to
everything is completely malleable
depending on what togashi wants to
happen however that sort of thing once
again not series breaking but the extent
of knowledge regarding the troop and how
they conduct themselves in the world is
like many other things in the series
simply inconsistent as is the knowledge
of nen
in general nan is probably the biggest
inconsistency of roland hunter hunter
not in terms of the system itself it's
actually quite absurdly brilliantly
thought out however it was pretty
blatantly inserted into a series that
was not originally intended to house it
that's why you have all of these hunter
exam arc inconsistencies like kilauea's
non-nun abilities you know stuff like
turning his
hands into a claw in the whole rhythm
echo technique stuff that was meant to
give the world a magical
supernatural feel but then ended up
being retconned internet stuff but it
also doesn't fit internet stuff so let's
just say it and not kid ourselves
nen did not exist when togashi began
writing the series and because tagashi
also doesn't give the most attention to
world building it's a tricky concept to
understand because it's meant to be this
incredibly well-kept secret
something that the hunter association
has an entire exam based around deciding
who
and who is not worthy of learning the
secret but at the same time the hunter
association has
no control whatsoever over this nen
secret because everyone knows about nen
unless they're not supposed to once
again we refer to the rules of hunter
hunter it's a rule until it isn't and
then it isn't
until it is again like take gantry for
example he is not a hunter and yet he
possesses advanced in-depth knowledge
about nen specifically the framework
taught by the shinken ryu school of kung
fu
the same can be said for the phantom
troop who must have become nen users in
isolation and yet
they practice men with the exact same
terminology as someone who was formally
taught but even common groups understand
men we have random residents of meteor
city that can use it
it was very common amongst the mafia
families of the ten dons many of the
karkin empire
bodyguards and end users as well as
their extended mafia families and there
was even that one random soldier in
escorto who was somehow an experienced
or a wielder and not to mention all of
the heaven's arena combatants on the
200th floor and beyond who publicly
showcase their inabilities on a regular
basis and sure they might be invisible
to the world watching them but the
effects of their abilities are not has
no one ever become curious as to exactly
how these superhuman fighters pull off
what would seem to be clear sorcery
stuff like castro making a full-on nen
body double that wasn't even invisible
because that ability was conjured so
from the perspective of everyone
watching that's just hard magic
nen is on full and easily accessible
display in the world and it also seems
to be quite simply studied and acquired
by those who have no ties to the hunter
association so my question is
how is nen still a secret how does
someone like 4th prince siradnik who has
every possible resource at his disposal
not come across this shockingly common
art form or any ultra wealthy individual
really
once again that's just hunter hunter
none is a secret until it isn't but then
it goes back to being a secret again
when it needs to be to turn to another
potential plot hole now in chapter 344
we receive a recap of how karapika has
acquired all of his scarlet eyes thus
far it's a profoundly interesting inner
monologue because it paints krapika as a
very changed man who has done some
seriously like shady and deep dark stuff
to take back these eyes and one
source of these eyes is identified as a
daughter of the mafia a clear reference
to neil nastrad who we remember wanted
nothing more than a pretty pair of
scarlet eyes to add to her collection of
the pretty things
now the problem here is that neon never
actually got those eyes krapika won them
at auction and delivered them but they
were actually the fabricated pair of
eyes crafted by cortopia's gallery fake
ability and the last that we seemingly
hear of these eyes is that they were
quote stolen which we all know means
that they just disappeared because
that's how courtois visibility works but
karapika in chapter 344 categorically
states that the only remaining eyes in
the world are those in possession of
saradnick so this is another instance
where togashi forgot his own convoluted
narrative and just went oh yeah well
karapika took the eyes from neon
eventually didn't he
that's probably what happened except
that neon didn't have the eyes for him
to take unless we want to embark on a
truly
truly tangled journey and say that the
phantom troop did put the real eyes on
the black market and neon won them again
however this wouldn't actually be
possible because after crollow stole
neon's netability her father
lightnistrad lost his source of income
which was selling her fortune
tellingness so he would not have been
able to purchase the eyes for his
daughter of course karapaka took over
the nastrad family and i suppose you
could argue that he used their funds to
buy the eyes regardless
if they somehow had the funds that is
but then in that case the statement
about gaining them through naon becomes
false so it's just
easier to slice this whole argument cake
up with a nice occam's razor and say
that togashi clearly forgot about the
eyes
plain and simple as such we will now
turn to icalgo and the burning issue of
names now many people forget this
including myself sometimes but our lion
and
leo actually had an original name which
was hagya and he changed his name to leo
to better reflect the individual that he
was becoming having more pride in his uh
his
lioness but this actually formed a
pretty major dramatic crux for the
ocargo character because he accidentally
referred to leo as hagia during the
palace invasion
whilst controlling flutter's body which
of course caused brother to become
highly highly suspicious of this flutter
because he
of all people should have known to call
him leol but the thing we kind of miss
at this point
is that also of all people who should
have known to call him leol would have
been icalgo because hicalgo was actually
a captain in a group that was literally
called the lael squad and he was even
working with the squad to hunt down
killua and this was
after leial had changed his name so from
any kind of reasonable standpoint
ikalgo should have known that hagia was
now called leo particularly as
cargo was a member of once again the
lael squad
to get around this we would need to
perform some sort of olympic level
mental gymnastics to force what actually
happened in the story what we would need
to do is insist that icalgo despite
being a direct subordinate of flutter
had no contact with the lael squad but i
mean if like
that premise already doesn't work
because flutter was in close contact
with the cargo via telepathy during this
whole kilowatt event but the weirdest
thing is that for whatever reason
neither flutter nor leol
nor anyone informed ikalgo of the name
change which seems really odd
considering how much lael hated being
referred to by his previous name it just
makes no sense ikalgo
should have known the only way that i'd
accept his ignorance
is if he was a member of a different
squad that happened to stumble upon
killua at the same
time as leo's group but he wasn't he was
a member of once again
the layol squad and so this whole name
business whilst being an incredibly
tense and wonderful moment during the
palace invasion
logically it well it never should have
been a thing unless they'd all gotten
together and decided to just
troll the calgo for fun which i wouldn't
put beyond someone like cleol he's a
sneaky funny lion dude but in the end it
just results in him getting trolled when
the name hoggier eventually comes up
again and he gets all like you know
lion angry but this is just a taste of
the many hunt hunter inconsistencies
this whole series is like a beautiful
mess of a puzzle that doesn't quite fit
together properly but it looks amazing
regardless and to explore this puzzle
some more here's another fun video for
you there's always more to learn explore
and experience about this wonderful
series so i look forward to seeing you
there